[Music]
hey y'all
time for another book review got a
really good one for you today and i'm
gonna say
the haunted house genre is probably
probably my favorite
sub genre of horror so anything
that purports to be a haunted house
story with kind of a twist or a little
bit of a fresh take on it
i really like classic haunted house
stories
but i really like to see what people can
do within the genre
so um i will say that this is
a very interesting and sort of a fresh
take on a haunted house
story this is 12 nights at
rotter house by j.w ocker
now i'm really i'm conflicted because
this book
has a twist ending
and it's really hard to
i don't know like i i feel like jus so
just tread carefully because i am going
to just like some
on some of my other reviews even if i
don't spoil the
ending outright and if i get to that
point and i just
decide and i chicken out and i just like
don't say what the ending is
then know even if i don't do that then
there might be some plot developments
that you don't want spoiled
so if you haven't read this book and you
really want to read this book and you
don't want to know anything that happens
in it then obviously
you might want to read the book first
and then come back and talk about it
because i'm not making any promises over
whether i spoil it or not
as i said i don't script these i
basically just read the book
and then turn on the camera and talk
about it
it all depends on when i get there when
i you know what in the book discussion
when i get there i'm like well
should i say what happens at the end so
i can kind of talk about the feels i had
about it so we'll see how it goes from
there so this book came out in 2019
now the author j.w ocker
i didn't know this and i haven't read
any of his sort of non-fiction books
but apparently he's quite well known for
doing
essentially what the protagonist of this
novel does he goes to
creepy haunted places and writes about
them
he's like a travel writer but with a
paranormal or you know a ghost story
sort of spin to it
so that's kind of what you have in your
main character now the main character is
named
felix alsie and
in the universe of the book he has
written several books
going to these haunted locations and
writing essentially a travel log about
them
and they've sold sort of enough for him
to
make a little bit of a living but
not really uh i guess there's there's
some stuff in there about his wife elsa
who uh i guess a lot of the stuff is you
know based on her salary
so he's kind of feeling bad about it and
he wants
that one book that's just gonna you know
blow the doors off and
you know make him kind of a household
name so how he thinks he's going to do
that
is there's a house i don't know if it's
near where he lives or it's like it
doesn't really matter but there was this
house that he heard about
and it was kind of a more obscure
haunted house and he can't
understand why it's so obscure because
it's really super creepy looking
and a bunch of really really horrible
[ __ ] happened there there was a lot of
murders and suicides
murder suicides you know a serial killer
huh like
used it as hideout for a while and stuff
like that so they're all kind of like
terrible things happen there
the guy that built the house i think his
name was al
rotterdam essentially called rotterdam
manor rotterdam mansion but because it
got a reputation for being creepy and
haunted it just started getting called
rotter house
so the guy that built the house was
much like this reminded me very much of
uh legend of hell house
and hell house the book that it was
based on by richard matheson where the
dude that built the house was kind of
a i guess you'd call him like a sex
addict
or something like where he had
essentially a harem
of women and he would have all these
women in there and doing all these
things to them so that it got a
reputation because of that and then
later on it became a brothel and then it
became like even worse brothel and then
there was you know what i mean so there
so there was all kind of
backstory to the house they don't go a
huge amount into it a lot of it is
suggestion but i kind of like the way
that was done they don't do a big
exposition dump
um you know there are some times where
he's talking about this is the room
where this happened but they don't go
super super into exactly what happened
in the house it's just a lot of it's
just
suggestion or just mentioned uh just to
give you kind of a background of
this house had a really sordid history
and is supposedly all full of ghosts
so what felix is going to do and this
novel is written in the first person
he thinks the book that's gonna make his
name he wants to do
a travelogue type book but one with
a twist or one with an edge he's like
basically what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
take
rotter house this house it's abandoned
it's owned by somebody who
is you know the the owner of the house
is saying that they're going to
you know fix it up and resell it or turn
it into
something like turn it into a bed and
breakfast or a haunted attraction or
something like that that's they don't
really go a lot into that either but
that seems to be the implication
so he wants to stay in this house and
essentially treat the house
like an immersion tank where he is gonna
go in this house
for 13 days and he's not going to leave
he's not going to have a cell phone he's
not going to do he's basically taking
a box of research into [ __ ] that
happened in the house
he's taking a few other things he's
taking like a whole bunch of food and
bedding and all that kind of crap
that you would take if you were going
camping or whatever and he's just going
to basically stay in this house for 13
days
and write about his experiences so he
thinks that this is going to be kind of
a fresh take on the genre
so there's a little bit of back and
forth in the beginning uh where the
woman who owns the house
really doesn't want to let him in there
and she's being uh you know
he keeps calling her a bastard because
she doesn't want to let him in there but
eventually he does get into the house
now one thing that i love about this
book being
called 12 nights at rotter house is that
very early on it's established that his
book that he's writing
in the book is called 13 nights at
rotter house
so you know that something is going to
go drastically awry and the whole [ __ ]
is gonna be
cut short so i like that even from the
first few pages you have that suspense
going on because you know
because it's kind of put into sections
where it's like night one you know all
this happened and then night two so
those are kind of like the chapters
so you know that like when night 12
comes that some bad shit's gonna go down
so you're kind of like constantly going
toward that
motion so like i said it's it's really
good suspense
now he stays there one night but then
the next day
it turns out that to make
this book more interesting he has asked
his childhood friend
thomas to stay in the house with him now
this is for several reasons felix is
a skeptic of the paranormal um he does
not believe in ghosts he doesn't believe
in anything like that and he's very very
adamant about it
he's really into horror movies and he's
really into horror tropes
so he wants to ascen it's not even like
i don't know if i want to say this but
it's almost kind of like he's
daring this house to prove that it's
haunted type of thing
because he wants to go in this house and
do all the regular [ __ ] that you would
do
in a haunted house story you know he's
got the ouija board
he's got some of the ghost hunting [ __ ]
he's got all this kind of stuff so he's
trying to like stir [ __ ] up because he's
almost kind of like you know
show me i you know i'm a skeptic i don't
believe anything is going to happen
but he also wants his friend thomas
there for one reason because thomas
is a believer in ghosts and uh he really
thinks this whole thing is maybe a bad
idea and maybe they shouldn't be [ __ ]
with a ouija board and maybe they
shouldn't be
calling these ghosts out and all this
other kind of stuff so there's a good
conflict there but also
these two friends they're both big
horror movie fans and some of the best
stuff in the book
some of the most fun stuff in the book
because this is a really fun book it's a
fun read there's creepy [ __ ] in it too
but i i think fun is the main adjective
that i would use to describe this it's
just a really
entertaining read and a lot of the
entertainment
comes from the humor as i said
this is written in the first person from
felix's point of view and he's a funny
guy and he's really into horror movies
and his friend thomas is also really
into horror movies and even though
they're coming at things from
sort of a conflicting philosophical
world view if you want to go that deep
with it where he's very very skeptical
of the paranormal and thomas is not
they still have a really deep and
abiding friendship and they have a lot
of fun
with all their horror trivia like that a
couple times in the book they play
this basically this game oh i can't
remember what it's called it's called
film something film
film fight i think it's called film
fight there we go and uh where they
basically
are like okay uh every movie that you
can think of that has a ouija board in
it and then
it just goes back and forth and they
have to like come up with all the movies
they can think of that had a ouija board
in them
and so all this kind of [ __ ] is really
fun and there's so
so so many horror references
in this and some people might think it's
a little excessive just like oh my
oh man you know knock it off but i found
it really really fun
really really entertaining i think my
favorite shout out was
when they go down in the basement and
they find kind of all these
uh like animatronic monsters and stuff
because they're like oh maybe the
you know maybe the owner is trying to
make it into a haunted attraction like
when it's all fixed up or whatever
so like werewolves and [ __ ] like that
down there and there's one
zombie animatronic down there that he
compares to dr freudstein from
lucio folgi's house by the cemetery and
that's how that figure is referred to
like for the rest of the book is dr
freudstein so i don't know i've found
that really amusing
but so obviously jw ocker the author
is really really into horror movies and
really into kind of obscure horror
movies
so i really liked that aspect of it this
is
i will say if you don't like meta horror
this does have a very very strong
meta aspect it's very self-aware
these two characters even though one's a
skeptic and one's not
they are both really into horror movies
and horror literature
and know a lot about it they're like
geeks about it essentially
and they talk a lot about it and they
talk a lot about haunted house tropes
and they talk about subverting them
so they have a lot of discussions over
the 12 nights that they're in this
house about different films like
you know it is this something we should
be doing oh we're splitting up right now
that means that this is gonna happen and
then they'll like reference some other
movie so if you don't like meta stuff
you might not
you might not enjoy it as much as
somebody that does but i i really like
meta horror if it's done well and i
think this was really done well because
this is also
a really entertaining story on top of
being
sort of meta self self referential self
aware
that type of stuff but i'm just warning
you if you don't like metahorry you
might not dig it the same way i did
so these two friends are in this house
and there's no electricity there's no
water apparently when he
conceived the project and that he was
going to be staying in this house for
almost two weeks he thought that the
house had electricity but then
when he got there and used up the last
of his cell phone because like i said he
was just let his cell phone battery die
because he wanted it to be like an
immersion experience and like no
no influence from the outside world um
he was led to believe that there would
be electricity
but he calls the owner and she's like oh
no you know it doesn't have any
electricity i believe it did have some
running water
but the water was kind of brown and
gross um but he brought lots of booze so
it was fine
so these two guys as i said have been
friends i believe since high school and
uh their wives are also friends with
each other so all four of them
you know the two couples are you know
very close friends however
something happened a year ago that
really put a massive rift in their
friendship
and it must have been something really
bad because they didn't speak
about it for a year and felix expresses
surprise that when he reached out to
thomas
and asked him to be on this project with
him that he accepted so you're led to
believe
that thomas wants to repair this rift in
their friendship over whatever it was
that happened a year ago that was
apparently very terrible and so that's
kind of another thing too like the
connection between these two men trying
to reconnect with one another
now for a long time you don't know
what the terrible thing was that
happened
between the two of them that severed
their friendship you do find out later
on
in the book and that's kind of where
that's the point at which
everything starts going [ __ ] crazy up
in the [ __ ]
but i think the heart of this book is
the relationship between the two of them
because you're seeing everything from
felix's point of view
and just the way they talk the way he
thinks about his friend the way they
talk to one another
i think that's really really well done
and because essentially these are the
only two characters in the entire book i
mean they talk about
their wives a little bit but you don't
ever get to see them or talk to them
the only other person that has any
dialogue or any
you know screen time if you want to call
it that in the book
is the owner of rotter house and that's
literally like the first two pages and
then you
never hear from her again really um so
at the very very beginning in the very
very end
there are a couple other people but
other than that
the whole the entirety of the book is
just these two men
interacting with each other and
interacting with this house
so over the course of the two weeks that
they are staying in this house
essentially camping out
as i said because felix's book he wants
to do something different every day
let's today let's do ouija board you
know tomorrow let's do
i don't think they did evp or anything
but they you know they do things like
that that ghost hunter people or that
people that are in haunted houses would
do
because they want some [ __ ] to happen
now for a long time
nothing really happens or nothing
happens that
is that doesn't have like plausible
deniability you know what i'm saying
because i think the first things that
happen when they're doing the ouija
board
is they start hearing these really loud
cracking noises and they can't figure
out where they're coming from like these
cracks
are really loud like so loud that they
shake the whole house and the cracks
seem to be moving through the house
as though because they're doing the
ouija board up in the attic
as though the cracking noise is leading
them down to the seller
so there's that but you know felix
basically says
well that could be something natural
even though it's very very loud and it's
very weird
but that's not unarguably
supernatural so things kind of go on
from there where they just hear
funny noises kind of like you know
creaking floorboards really loud cracks
felix actually on the first night he's
there before like right before thomas
arrives
he has a really bad he doesn't see
anything but he kind of sees
all these nightmarish images in his
mind's eye which gives him
sort of a panic attack so there's that
kind of stuff
so it's little things loud cracks he
thinks when he's
in bed one night that he's hold like he
dreams that he's holding his wife's hand
but when he wakes up
he still feels as though he's holding
someone's hand but there's no one there
which is very haunting of hill house
because that happens in that novel
as well so it's little things but then
you get to a point where you can't deny
that this [ __ ] is haunted anymore and
felix
actually sees at first he sees
a figure and it just kind of passes by a
door
and he can tell that it's a woman but he
can't see her face
he's like the only impression i got was
that she was i think the word he used
was flowy
like something was flowing along behind
her like hair or
clothing or something but he didn't see
her face
so for a long time they're trying to
figure out
who this ghost might be because
as i said many people died in this house
and one of the very amusing things is
that when felix and thomas first start
exploring the house
felix has done all of this research
about the house
and so he knows all of the horrible [ __ ]
that has happened in each bedroom
because this is a massive house that has
i don't even remember how many bedrooms
it has but it's a lot
and so he writes down on a piece of
paper he's like this is the
dismemberment room and this is the
hanging suicide room or whatever
so he like marks them all to you know um
in regards to whatever horrible thing
happened in that particular room because
something horrible happened in every
single room
so he's almost not he's not really
taking it seriously it's almost kind of
like a lark
to him so you know he has a kind of a
morbid sense of humor about it so he's
doing that kind of stuff so they're
trying to figure out
they're like because felix is saying all
of the stuff that supposedly happened in
this house all of these horrific murders
it's very difficult to find because a
lot of them happened so long ago it's
very difficult to find any independent
sources for these so some of them may be
urban legends however
one murder a double murder or
murder-suicide they're not entirely sure
what
happened in 1984 and he does have a lot
of documentation for
that and this was a case of this couple
that stayed in this one room where he
actually ends up
sleeping you know one of the master
bedrooms and
they found these two in bed and they had
basically
looked like they had cut each other up
like cut each other to pieces and they
couldn't really figure out why or
if someone else did it or if they did it
to each other or
or what it was it was like a really
really weird like unsolved murder
so for a long time this female ghost
that he sees
he thinks that that that it's the woman
of you know part of this couple so they
keep expecting like the dude ghost to
show up
but then it so happens as i said when he
sees the apparition the first time he
can't tell what she looks like
and then she shows up
pretty much big as life and twice as
ugly and i will say that the imagery of
this
imagining what this ghost would look
like
legitimately creeped me out like because
after i read this book because this book
as i said it's super fun it's super
entertaining and
it really i read it almost all in one
sitting
which i say a lot a lot about some of
the books on here but
not always but this one was just a
breeze i just breezed through it i was
having a blast
but after i finished reading the bulk of
it and i was going to bed and i got up
in the middle of the night like to go to
the bathroom or something and i was
thinking about
what that ghost must look like and i was
like like i didn't want to look in the
mirror
so basically he calls this ghost the
split-faced
woman and he essentially walks
into her at one time as in he's walking
down the hall and he just walks in and
suddenly he's in the middle
of the skin he can see her pulsing brain
like her face is split open
and you can see bone and brain and
everything and just the way it's
described in the book just really
freaked me out i don't know why
now it's strange because so he sees this
apparition
more than once and
he's he keeps arguing with thomas he's
like this must be some other murder
victim because this doesn't look
anything
like the woman that died here in 1984
who were who we're assuming that it is
so he's trying to come up with a
narrative it's really interesting
because because he's coming at things
from a skeptical point of view
even when he sees the ghost he
acknowledges that it's a ghost and him
and thomas get into
a lot of arguments about this because
thomas is like dude
you walked into a ghost and you're still
like hanging out here and not
taking it entirely seriously because
it's almost like felix is not kind of
like oh hey cool because he's scared
but it's almost like he wants to get to
the bottom of it he wants to find some
narrative why is this ghost here what's
going on
and he's dead set on finishing this book
because he thinks that this book
is going to save everything it's going
to save his marriage it's going to save
you know his his financial future
it's going to you know make him feel
like he's not useless anymore so this
is he's right everything is riding on
this project
so he's very very loathe to even after
thomas is
freaking out he's like we got to get out
of here like when really horrible [ __ ]
starts to happen
he just he's very very reluctant to
leave
now so it starts going on like that
they're trying to figure out who this
ghost is
and on the 12th night
or actually maybe it's on the 11th night
thomas
seems to disappear for i believe
24 hours and then reappears again
and after this point after his
reappearance
is when the twist happens okay
so i decided now that i got to this uh
point in the video
i decided i'm not gonna spoil what the
twist is
now i did not see it coming however
some other reviewers that i read
did see it coming so i'm not gonna say
oh you won't see it coming or it'll just
it'll blindside you or whatever i'm not
gonna say that because i did see some
reviewers that said oh i figured it out
earlier i did not because i guess i was
just so
wrapped up in the escalating haunting
and i was wrapped up in the
characterization of these two men
and wondering what had happened between
them a year ago that messed up their
friendship so badly that
you know the way that felix was thinking
about it and i was like man this must
have been really terrible
so i was just so wrapped up in all of
that and
in felix's interior monologue how he
felt about the book how he felt about
the
haunting getting worse you know how he
was coming at it is this
this is going to change my whole entire
worldview do i have to believe in
bigfoot now
it's like he gets into that kind of and
i thought it was like really realistic
because that's probably
probably what you know me as a skeptic
if i was staying at a haunted house i
feel like his thought process
processes about it were very similar to
probably what mine would have been
so i could really relate to him as a
character
so at the point when thomas reappears
in the house and as i said there is a
twist
i okay i will say for a minute
maybe two minutes when i realized
what was going on what the twist was for
a minute or two i went
oh are we doing this but then
i was all right with it so i'm not
really sure how you're going to feel but
it's not the most original twist
and as i said you might be able to see
it coming if you're picking up on
different clues that i'm picking up on
i did not see it coming and for you know
a fraction
of time i was kind of like oh
is it gonna do but then i was like oh
you know what no it's okay
because the more i thought about the
twist the more i thought back
to all the [ __ ] that had happened in the
book and i was like oh
oh okay i was like i see what he was
setting up the whole time
and i didn't see it so good one so this
is definitely a book
that i will reread
because after i finished reading it for
a day or two after
i kept thinking oh i kept thinking of
all these details in the earlier part of
the book and i was like oh
dear i was like oh [ __ ] why didn't i
even see that i should have totally seen
that ending coming
and i didn't so the way that it was
written was really skillful from
up i thought because as i said i didn't
really see it coming but
after you know what the ending is you
kind of go back
and think of all the details and be like
oh
oh i see what he was getting at with
that i see
so as i said this is definitely when i
want to read a second time because i
want to
i like to do that with um stuff that i
really enjoyed that had kind of a twist
ending that i didn't see coming
i like to reread it a second time so i
can pick up all the [ __ ] that i lost
because i think it
gives a richer appreciation of the
writer's craft of
planting all these clues in there and
seeing if you can figure out
what the twist is gonna be it's not so
much like a puzzle or anything like that
but i just really liked
it was just very satisfying to me to
think about oh that's why that ghost
looked like that that's why this
happened that's why this happened
and it's it's just really satisfying for
me to
think of all the stuff and think about
how it was all set up and how
how the trick was done i guess if you
want to put it that way even though as i
said
even without the twist i think that this
book
would have still been a blast i thought
it was
really really fun it's funny and it also
is really creepy like it has some really
creepy imagery some really creepy
descriptions of what the inside of the
house looks like
it's very claustrophobic because other
than one scene at the very beginning
the entire thing takes place in this
house which there's no electricity so
it's just dark
so they're just creeping around with
flashlights and lanterns all the time
so it's very very oppressive but also
i really liked the two characters and i
think these were the perfect two
characters to put in a situation
like this in a novel like this because
you had such a good time
i mean seriously i could have read a
whole book of just them
shooting the [ __ ] about horror movies
you know what i mean so even if you
didn't have all the other creepy ghost
[ __ ] it could have just been a whole
book of these two guys and like they're
in this house and nothing happened you
know what i mean
that was like a novel about that it
didn't need all this stuff with the
ghost and everything but i'm glad it had
that because that [ __ ] was creepy and
that was really cool
but i'm just saying it didn't need that
because the characterization was so good
and you
and i had such a good time with these
two characters that
i was you know going on a journey with
it and it was just really cool
so as i said if you like haunted house
stories
if you like meta stories if you like
stuff that
is creepy but also really funny and
references a lot of other horror movies
and is doing something
not completely original but a little bit
original
with the haunted house genre and with
all the haunted house tropes
and if you like a good twist ending as i
said not the most original twist ending
but you know what is
um so if you'd like anything like that
then please please
uh pick up 12 nights at rotterhouse by
jw ocker
it's really really fun and i really had
a good time
reading this one and as i said this will
be a definite reread
probably sometime later this year and if
i get any new insights
when i read it a second time uh maybe
i'll make a new video so we'll see
but yeah thanks for tuning in this time
and i'll see on the next one
bye